i saw um amsterdam
oh let me shut up man
oh yeah amsterdam right yeah so the
prostitutes be uh recoupable as well in
amsterdam um i played for my own horse
i'm just curious
if you go to if you go to the red light
district
on a promo tour
can you invoice the label for the
prostitutes i think you can
at least back then you probably could
have no nowadays you can't let's be
honest nowadays that's not happening i
don't know i'll pay for 0-1
yeah yeah
have you done the new the amsterdam
thing i've never been like at the
brotherhood yeah yeah amsterdam thing
yeah every time i went there how was it
i would
i want to get yo i'm about to give you a
fake ass answer
um
[Music]
the experience was cool
but i'm like i'm like i'm one of them
dudes that like
so like these girls are in the window
mm-hmm
and
they like in these apartment buildings
when you walk up the stairs they tell
you what number they are like what
number are you on my number 16. and you
know you gonna knock on her door she's
like in a [ __ ]
closet basically
with some lights and [ __ ] so
you then you look and then she got like
a thousand condoms in her dresser and
baby wipes over here so you know i i got
to feel like i'm being loved like i got
to [ __ ] you my girlfriend
you almost have to have her come to the
hotel i need to look in your eyes
looking at your soul
you know i'm not going to lie that
surprises me that that's just based on
like who i think you are off of the
music
i would not expect that i'd expect you
to be like yeah bro [ __ ] 99 had 11
prostitutes in one room on the red light
district so so i didn't coke off my dick
off my ass in the side of my [ __ ]
anyway jesus you had a chick blows coke
up your ass no no that sounds that
sounds sketchy i rap about it yeah
it sounds like a [ __ ] you watch the
beginning of snowfall season one oh yeah
where the chick dies because they yeah
or is it the guy that dies the guy died
because the girls were blowing cocaine
up as well
so i did it a lot of times but i never
really busted or not doing this [ __ ]
because it would it felt like it was
it was fake like you know what i'm
saying that's fair
so it was hard for you to like reach
full climax messing with women you paid
for it
i mean just and after getting bad for i
felt like she was a slave or something
yeah cause you see you you see 50
condoms on the [ __ ] she got a bowl of
condoms and
wipes over here i'd like to point out
guys her beds on the floor this is a
great opportunity to just point out
bizarre is a great guy
obviously a character on these records
you care yeah i was trying to rescue
them girls man
i must start a foundation for them man
that came my next check to